[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2018 I'm Mike McCarty
here with Lucy James as always hello and
we have an exciting guest in an exciting
game on our stage right now we're here
with Kyle Rowley hello hi design
director at CD Projekt yes associate
design director at CD Projekt RED work
non-stop I act yes cyberpunk 2077 right
so the trailer finally released yeah
what two days ago now it's about the
open our man is such a relief for it to
confine you care huh yeah yeah it was
routed in secrecy yeah one of the
studios super hyped we're super excited
to see the reactions and everything so
yeah I'm just I'm really happy I'm
really excited about seeing people
seeing what without the stuff we have to
show so yeah it's been one of the most
asked about games since like so cut if I
remember correctly it got announced even
before the Witcher 3 well yeah I got no
wasn't a 15 yeah yeah it's been a while
now so let's talk about the trailer we
can we can talk about gameplay right we
have a knife into that we can take
actually let's just dive into that I
think that's what he's probably wants to
know about so what can you tell us about
the gameplay that the trailer might not
have made clear okay so a few things so
first of all the game is a first-person
perspective role-playing game okay
there's a few reasons for that the main
thing that we really you know we're
spending a lot of time on creating this
like a very detailed sorry open-world
setting night city very it's all hand
crafted there's a lot of atmosphere we
really want the player to feel the like
the depression and the fact that like
these mega corporations are kind of
stamping down on people's lives and kind
of like this and it's a kind of really
showcased that and to kind of really
immerse the player in that world we
decided that the first-person
perspective was the best way of doing it
and so it's first-person doesn't mean
it's the first-person shooter or
anything like that the game is
definitely a role-playing game so I
really want to emphasize the fact that
it's a role-playing game with some
shooter elements rather than like a
first-person shooter with a bit of a
role played lay it on top we have very
deep progression systems so all the
things you would expect from a CD
Projekt RED game a lot multiple
different regression systems actually
skills attributes perks like cyber
obesity so
it's definitely a role-playing game in
the first-person perspective and you
were saying there are you gonna start
with like a base character and build
them out or they're gonna be classes
that you start from or hell that way the
player takes on the role of V she's like
an urban mercenary hired gun she takes
on dangerous jobs or he or she actually
she takes on dangerous jobs that no one
else will and I was talking about before
we really wanted to give this feeling of
the city being quite oppressive so in
order to kind of break free from this
oppression she really has to the players
really focused on completing these
different missions freeing himself from
the state building their own defining
their own rules so the player plays us v
and yeah we have a full character
creation system in the game and as you
be able to define your gender
whether it's male or female you'll be
able to define how you look so we have
various different body types hair styles
clothes tattoos makeups and many many
more and obviously you can define your
what we're calling life path is like a
backstory and the things you define in
your life path and your backstory can
modify or unlock different things that
you're playing through the game now at
the start of the game we don't actually
have any kind of classes the classes
that you pick from okay that's the it
obviously in Saipan 2020 there's a lot
of different roles that you can put a
con so corporate rocker boy and they're
silent netrunner techy etc at the start
of the game you're not picking any of
those classes basically as you're
progressing through the game you're
modifying and adjusting your class based
on their tributes the perks you pick the
side where you install so it's a very
fluid class system we don't lock you in
at the very start of the game or
anything like that so I'm outside of the
obvious like cyberpunk 2020 the property
what were some outside influences that
you guys looked at for a building night
city I mean a lot of people immediately
we're saying Blade Runner during the
trailer but what are some of those
influenced that fact yeah I mean like as
you can see in the trailer the we
focused a lot on kind of trying to build
the cyberpunk atmosphere in daytime
because we know for a fact that we can
create the kind of moody atmospheric
noir feeling that you get from Blade
Runner so for the trailer we really
wanted to
showcase how you can take the cyberpunk
elements of like this dystopian world
and kind of and show it when the sun's
out so like because it's not something
that you necessarily experience in
traditional cyberpunk media but that's
not to say we don't have those Blade
Runner noir like enamines actually one
of the terms that we're phrasing for the
game stories like game noir like the
story is very why and how and how it
works at the feeling and that the
different kind of missions and
characters are interacting with it
definitely has that noir vibe so if
anyone's worried that we're not going to
have this kind of Blade Runner nor
feeling it's definitely going to be
there the game folk the game has a full
day night cycle with weather systems so
yeah you get to experience both day
daytime and nighttime and for sure we'll
have that neon cityscape that people
really are craving for what I think I
was interested in finding out is how
you've taken psychic 2020 and like try
to take the design elements from that
and how you can translate those into a
video game yeah yeah compared to a
tabletop I mean we work in super closely
with Mike pon Smith who's like the
creator of the twenty20 rule book both I
mean for sure there's a lot of aspects
from the twenty20 rule book which is
built into the law so obviously we take
that the city is also the city itself is
based niceties based on the 2020
rulebook there's a lot of characters
from 2020 who will make an appearance in
in 2077 we can't go into details about
how it will work or anything like that
but for sure there'll be this characters
from the law that you can expect to find
there and then obviously in terms of
the gameplay side as I said before the
classes and the roles that are prevalent
in in the game we're kind of focusing on
three main ones for the actual game
itself so netrunner techy and the solo
and but it's not like as I said it's not
like you kind of pick one at the start
and then you just play it for the way
through you basically perhaps your your
class your archetype as you're playing
through the game so hypothetically you
can have bits of techy and bits of
netrunner and bits of solo and and you
can kind of combine them and the other
cool classes they're in there like in
the game in general like rocker boy in
corporate they're kind of more in there
from a lore perspective from a story
perspective you're Lee during your
encounter characters who represent those
rock those are other alternate roles but
it's not something that we're going to
allow the player to necessarily play
with it's such an like a such a
different aesthetic obviously than The
Witcher a fantasy inspired which was
also based on you know like existing
properties but what were some of the
biggest lessons that the team took from
their other properties which are 1 2 3 3
especially being the you know like the
studio was you know maybe witch or 2 was
its breakout game but witcher 3 was just
a phenomenon right or were some of the
biggest lessons that the team found from
witcher 3 that really wants to implement
cyberpunk I mean for sure the like how
we build how we build an immersive world
I like the attention to detail that we
that we want to put in Witcher 3
we're doing the same thing again but in
like a completely new genre for us we
really obviously we were very proud of
how the the story and quest system is in
Witcher so we're taking all of that
stuff that we learned from Witcher 3 and
we're taking and putting inside of Punk
like as I said at the start I really
wanna emphasize the fact that we're a
role-playing game first and foremost and
not like a shoot or anything like that
it's we choice in consequence of your
actions like how you interactive
characters and the choices you make and
how that affects the story is super
important we're an arat of driven
company first and foremost just like I
think the one thing that we're super
passionate about and super proud about
and obviously the role-playing aspect as
well so yeah how we built those quests
and how we got the player immersed in
those stories and and yeah those are the
kind of things that we really want to
translate to cyberpunk we we're not
really looking to build this epic tale
that kind of is say is like a save the
world kind of story
in the same vein of
The Witcher games we're really focused
on like personal stories like like
personal stories of the people in the
world and personal stories for the 4 vs
the V as herself as well so one of the
things it's really special about CD
Projekt is the relationship that you
guys have with your fans like in
particular like Witcher
the way that you handle DLC and you're
very open and talking about talking to
the fans about the games that you're
making
obviously with cyberpunk you announced
and then went quiet for so long but even
in your like sort of reveal trailer you
kind of apologized yeah for that going
forward like what kind of relationship
we're gonna be having with getting
details about cyberpunk out I mean we're
gonna be significantly more open I think
I think that's that's the first thing I
mean that's why we're so excited really
because it's there this is the it's a
start of us being able to talk about the
game we've been working on it for quite
a long time and we have a lot of
information to share with people and so
I would for sure expect more information
being fed out over the over then over
the next X amount of time I don't really
want to yeah yeah yeah so yeah for sure
we're going to be I'll be will be will
be interacting on social media will be
interacting on the forums like we'll be
answering questions obviously there's
some things that we don't we don't with
a story is one thing that we're not very
we want to keep that it under wraps but
will be more it will be open to talking
about how the gameplay works what you do
what the player can do in the game so
yeah and we're gonna be definitely be
more open I would saying can you talk a
little more I mean you're saying it's
not gonna be it's obviously not a
shooter it's an RPG but still I think
people if you could talk about are
probably curious about how combat will
work in general okay yeah so we have
both ranged combat so we have guns and
we have melee based combat as well so
and obviously we learn quite a lot from
the combat in Witcher 3 and we're
translating that I can kind of go back
to your other question we're translating
that's the lessons we learned in the
gameplay about how how to kind of how to
do melee and try and transfer to the
cyberpunk obviously it's very different
in the fact that we're down doing it
from a first-person perspective rather
than from the third-person but the
lessons that we learned in which we can
definitely translate
yeah so weapons wise we have basically
the three main types of weapons that you
can three kind of brat kind of gameplay
theme style weapons that we have we have
power weapons which are focused zidane
like like traditional weapons that you
would have in our days so there when you
when you fire them they they we may have
exaggerated hit reactions and staggers
to kind of emphasize the hit impacts and
then we have tech weapons which are kind
of focused on penetrating through walls
and objects and NPCs and stuff like that
and then we have smart weapons which are
basically weapons which can track and
follow targets around the game we could
again because and I keep going back to
it because we're role-playing game and
we understand some people aren't
necessarily averse to twitch face combat
who like playing role-playing games we
try to design a example the smart
weapons around being something that
people can pick up and play casually
without necessarily have to being super
efficient with shooting people in the
head or like you know more twitch based
reaction based combat so we're trying to
cater to both audiences there with that
so yeah so horses are gone but it looks
like there's flying cars is that how
we're gonna be getting around we will be
going around in vehicles okay we're only
really we're only really talking about
right now is that for sure we're gonna
have motor motorcycles and we're going
to have drivable cars okay the other
other vehicles that potentially in the
game we're not talking too much about
that stuff right now I mean we have them
obviously in the trailer yeah the the
ABS and for sure they're going to be a
big narrative there we gonna be
narrative set pieces where we utilize
ABS a lot but we're not talking about
anything about the actual really okay as
you play as V is really gonna be voiced
yep so we have a bow for male and female
voice to be for us we went it's in the
same way we've had we had with Darryl as
a studio it's we feel we can create more
interesting and deep stories like
activate our stories are quite character
driven so for us having someone who's
voiced and is a named character it
allows us to build relationships better
with characters so that's why we decided
to go with a named parrot so rather than
necessarily having like a blank slate
with no name or in
just can do completely whatever you want
with savvy in a sense does have a her
own kind of personality but you shape it
as a player so depending on how your
backstory that you select the star and
how you interact with characters you can
kind of shape be as a person that you're
playing through the game's the cyberpunk
aesthetic and genre I guess is so much
less established than fantasy what's it
like working with cyberpunk and being
able to do this kind of like dystopia as
opposed to this fantasy world I mean I
think that even in which even in Witcher
3 we were kind of more dark fantasy than
necessarily high fantasy yeah so I think
we're quite good at telling stories
which the most you know happy stories in
the world I think the biggest difference
for us is obviously the fact that the
feeling of the world is just very
different from what we did in Witcher 3
and the feeling of the world and trying
to understand the technology that is in
the world and and and we spend an awful
lot of time and it's something that as a
studio again we were quite proud of is
that we spend a lot of time figuring out
details of the world it's law making
sure it's believable it has a purpose
like and I mean cyberpunk is actually
set in an alternative timeline to our
own so it's not like in 2077 it's a
future based on a future as it is right
now it's kind of based on a future from
like the 1890s cyberpunk future so it's
not like we can just take what we see
here and try and transfer it or again we
have to reinvent things like how was
based on what I was before in old in
previous like a punk [ __ ] sure is it
like a Southern California influenced
area yeah so it's set in night city
which is on the some of the coast of
California it's in between actually Los
Angeles and San Francisco okay cool
but it's a fictional city yeah so again
we can it gives us liberties to
basically do as we want
obviously there's heavy inspiration from
like Los Angeles and San Francisco and
San Diego and all those kind of things
we have all those elements in the city
and a bit like in really wanted to kind
of emphasize the fact that it's the six
unique districts inside the sea so it's
not like when you're when you're
traveling through it's going to feel the
same all the time it kind of comes back
to my what I was talking about when we
want it you'll have the noir feeling in
your and you'll have a data nice cycle
you'll also have kind of more up capped
areas with there like high rich
corporate sustain but you'll have areas
like Pacifica
which are kind of totally overrun with
gangs and the state they kind of own the
streets it's very depressing like
poverty is like everywhere so it's like
you're definitely where's your traveling
through the city and your different
districts you'll definitely feel the
difference between the district so it
won't feel the same wherever you're
playing okay we really want to encourage
the player to explore night city so any
of a big difference obviously is that we
Witcher is very like wide landscape like
horizontal whereas for cyberpunk we're
really pushing verticality more so we
have a lot of buildings you can enter
which have a lot of flaws in them so you
can explore we have some things called
like mega buildings which are kind of
like these huge complex micro societies
in on themself they have like vendors
and shops and gunsmiths and apartment
blocks and what I kind of serve all
inside like one big building so when you
exploring the world you go inside a mega
building you're like okay and now I'm
going to explore inside here and see
what I can find there's like stories to
be told there's like quests to find
missions to go on stuff like that so are
you able to talk it all about like does
vide level up and stuff as she goes
along how is that going to work within
the context of like such a huge world
with sidequest main quests things going
to scale to your level can you over
level yourself we're not we're not doing
any kind of levels level scaling really
I mean we basically have two forms of
experience we have like standard
experience which you'll gain from
completing find core missions and then
we have what we call street cred which
is an alternate experience you gain from
doing side missions so and naturally
when you're completing both main mission
mine quests and side quests you kind of
get a bit of both but we kind of
separate that we split the amount of
each XP depending on if you're doing a
main or side mission so main missions
kind of get core XP and cyan side
missions get the street cred Street
creds basically a way for you to based
on your street cred level you can unlock
different vendors and will unlock
different fixes so it fixes are kind of
like mission givers in this world right
so they'll give you jobs to do and you
get access to new fixers as you're kind
of leveling up your street cred so okay
well Kyle unfortunately that's all the
time we have but thank you so much for
shedding more light on cyberpunk yeah
everybody has had questions for years
now so it's nice to be getting some of
them answered definitely thanks a lot my
name's Ben yeah absolutely have a good
rest of the week and I might or might
not but definitely will maybe get to
play the game later today excited about
yes but anyway thank you so much copper
no worries thank you thank you very much
and if you're at home keep around
GameSpot stick around GameSpot we will
have the Amazing Adventures of Captain
Spirit on very shortly we'll see you
then
[Music]
you